[Music]
maybe when you think of Africa this is
what you imagine but it's so much more
this vast continent is made up of more
than 50 countries it is home to nearly
one and a quarter billion people
including me and my family I was brought
up here and loved Africa it's in my
blood but even as a child
Africa's exploitation by foreign powers
was clear to me and now working here
it's still all too apparent decisions
made thousands of miles away are
impacting on Africans and actions in
African nations are affecting them and
everyone else around the world we're
going to take you to parts of Africa you
may not have seen from rural Malawi to
the terrorists battlefields of Northeast
Nigeria and then right down to the lush
Niger Delta where the conflict there is
over oil but first we're going to the
Democratic Republic of Congo where
children are working in atrocious
conditions to honor the product whose
name they know but whose value they do
not and it's a mineral the world cannot
seem to do without this is one of the
thousands of unregulated unmonitored
mines in the DRC it's crawling with
children working like modern-day slaves
a 12-hour long day of punishing work may
earn them the equivalent of a pound
although one of the poorest countries on
earth DRC is rich in minerals but a
history of brutal colonial exploitation
looks like being repeated now in 2017
much of its mined by hand with
rudimentary tools in harsh potentially
hazardous conditions
and wretched whether or not the rush is
on for a mineral the DRC has in great
abundance cobalt and it's fast becoming
more precious than gold it's a critical
ingredient in lithium-ion batteries
which power smartphones and laptops an
army of children are at the heart of the
mining production wearing no shoes and
in the most wretched conditions
Dawson is ordered to retrieve the sack
he's forgotten there's an urgency now
the rains make this dangerous work even
more risky and Dawson's told in no
uncertain terms he risks a beating if he
messes up again Dawson with Richard
beside him have worked all day they're 8
and 11 years old even astonishing work
doesn't guarantee enough for food
Dawson hasn't eaten for two days now
this is what helpless looks like and
he's one of the children making millions
for multinational corporations in
America and China whilst they suffer in
squalor for this they'll get maybe eight
British pence a day
- guess I win win Oh
[Applause]
[Music]
the tunnels are dug by hand with no
supports they frequently collapse
especially during rain the miners
climbed down using holes carved in the
rock and no safety equipment this most
precious of minerals is often extracted
and sorted by tiny hands
they don't wear gloves or masks yet the
World Health Organization says exposure
to cobalt and breathing in its dust
fumes can cause long-term health
problems we visited five different mines
across the south of DRC and found all
used child workers monikers the youngest
worker in this group at just four but
even those barely able to walk have lost
their childhoods to mining nataly's
twelve years old my fingers hurt she
tells us miles away on a different site
macumba metemma
the cobalt tunnel he's dug with three of
his friends it's physically tough work
they removed all this rock by hand over
nearly four months it's incredibly
insecure for them although this is
really rich in minerals and it's going
down just 15 meters there's no support
bars there's there's they have no
protective masks or protective equipment
at all and right at the bottom I can see
water
it's his villages water which Macumba is
convinced has caused his health problems
after a lifetime of drinking it he has a
huge tumor on his throat that won't keep
that too much and red they give to this
he he
there are countless reports of other
health problems from those living nearby
and working on the minds compulsory SFX
yo mama these twins are just two days
old and although small so far they're
healthy to the relief of their mother
take em when I mean she was I'm gay you
couldn't born in my mind you're gonna
need to be like a cook with some Amway
and joking into vinegar to indicate a
mix but even if they stay healthy
the twins face a lifetime of hard labor
as soon as they can walk the children's
cobalt is sold cheaply to mostly Chinese
traders who we film secretly they don't
ask questions about where their cobalt
comes from all whose work to extract it
they just want the best price even those
who aren't Chinese this trading market
has Indian owners toll as they sell on
to the dominant Chinese exporter of
cobalt CDM the cobalt first mined here
is then sold again to the Chinese parent
company which then supplies some of the
world's biggest battery makers and those
batteries with ingredients which
originated in DRC end up in for instance
smartphones it's an intricate supply
chain which allows easy deniability for
the multinationals making huge profits
an investigation last year by amnesty
found similar human rights abuses
nothing appears to have changed most of
these child miners will never own a
smartphone they barely survive from day
to day and many other children like
Dawson will be back again tomorrow
digging out one of the most sought-after
minerals of our time for a pittance
from DRC to Malawi where the young a
doomed before they're even born women
are secretly killing their unborn babies
and the villages are so remote the women
often end up dying too village is at
least 10 kilometers away from the
nearest health center and most of the
roads are very small they don't have
vehicles that it could take them say
three hours to get to the nearest health
center where there's no hospital
there are no doctors they dance to
encourage fertility and to celebrate
menstruation but in Malawi falling
pregnant can mean a death sentence for a
woman in this poorest of communities
cultural traditions are strong and
contraception is still taboo that makes
the man on the stilts a very important
village elder he's the one who can make
unwanted babies disappear he's a senior
member of a secretive cult and everyone
here believes that gives him special
powers
he shows us his abortion potion made
from a rare plant
it's sap is mixed with water a few sips
will not only kill the unborn baby but
puts the mother in terrible danger too
is one of the ways in which I generate
some income when I assist women in
terminating their pregnancies I'm able
to buy some food and even some tablets
of breathing heavily after administering
our our hips there is no intervention
that we can give them actually when we
see that this situation we advise them
to go to the hospital but caution me
they are not to reveal what I think
they're coming from abortions are
strictly banned in Malawi unless the
mothers lives in danger
he faces 14 years jail if court and
makes his confession to us all the more
remarkable but he believes his cult will
protect him we know that the government
has is strict and a tough role only the
same but he in the village we do it
secretly and occur in this tiny and if
people if people come I will refuse
explaining that I do it but the
villagers know that I do it we're going
to call him Mary she's a wanted criminal
- and if we identify her she faces seven
years behind bars for having an abortion
her husband demanded her third child was
six months old when she became pregnant
again
the family just couldn't afford another
child and safer the doctors removed her
uterus a terrible stigma in her
her husband left her and she was thrown
out of the Community House completely
devastated and heartbroken I was very
worried and I started blaming myself
especially when I elected I do apart
from just losing my uterus I will died I
felt sorry for myself and I suffer there
are many more in a long ways main
hospital with the same terrible secret
1/3 of beds and the maternity ward are
filled with women meeting post abortion
care we talked to a group of them all
terrified of being arrested
Ruth again not her real name is a
student abandoned by the father but then
it was my plans having some other things
I want in my Ruth like all the others
now need surgery but for her this is a
new beginning
each one of them is a survivor against
the odds living in a country with one of
the world's highest maternal mortality
rates where one or two women die every
day many from illegal abortions as the
medics operate on roofs they stress how
much Malawi's Health Service depends on
overseas aid much of it from America
Ruth is going to be alright but
president Trump's tough line on cutting
funding to groups involved in any
abortion related work will heavily
impact other women here these women
sometimes they end up we end up are
taking out the whole uterus during a th
because of that necrotic uterus for the
methods that they use so I feel like it
says it's a bit unfair for a woman to
have to go through that those
complications caused us was forced to do
that the expectation is a cut in aid
will mean the numbers of women dying
will go up not just in Malawi but
throughout the developing world at
police level we are deliberately
creating an environment of sending so
many women to the grave when we have a
solution of making sure we provide safe
abortion so this will carry on yeah the
village healer here is a 75 year old
woman who gives her pregnant patients
dried wood shavings it flushes out
everything she says as we're talking to
more customers turn up they don't know
they risk losing everything they just
can't be pregnant and this is the only
way they know to fix it right now
in the northeast of Nigeria Africa's
most populous nation is fighting a war
against Islamic militants Boko Haram is
terrorizing people the extremists are
caroled by the military but they're not
yet civilians who are all trying to
travel up north and they need an armed
escort people from the anti-terrorist
unit as well as soldiers to ensure that
they get there safely and they come
under regular attack from Boko Haram the
militants have sent millions fleeing and
left a legacy into the next generation
[Music]
they're known as Boko Haram brides
forced to marry militant fighters are
now caring for the babies born from rape
[Music]
try to have sex with me when I refuse
will be beating me when he is tired of
beating me he will now push me down and
press me down and make use of me the
teenagers still barely out of childhood
themselves free may be but outcasts
anywhere we still they will just get
away everybody have known that our
husbands were into killings and now they
feel that if they should stay in the
same area with us we will one day rise
up and be killing them they're not the
only ones with the right babies they
were held in the same piece of forest
alongside the chibok schoolgirls taken
nearly three years ago even the same
mats and greet each other I've spent
time together with each other
the military crackdown is hurting the
terror group allied to is but they're
becoming more extreme girls not brides
are turned into bombers this
fourteen-year-old was caught three weeks
ago her suicide vest hidden under her
hijab her friend blew herself up here's
she's saying they were both taken by
Boko Haram and paid just 200 Nara to
kill that's about 40 British pence
terror comes cheap when you're
frightened and young these are very
unfortunate children little girls who
have been involved who have engaged too
many Koreans of these industry acts of
foreign terrorists so in my view it's a
sheer act of desperation millions have
fled the terror group and are now living
in camps this one in Mara guria is
thought to be the biggest in Africa
50,000 people are here they live with
soldiers guarding them the children
fight to get into schools a chance of an
education banned as evil by Boko Haram
[Music]
going to class would invite an attack
from the terrorists before Boko Haram
made me scared to go to school she says
but now we have security I can learn the
brutality of Boko Haram is meted out to
all who resist this is one of their
fighters but when he tried to escape his
disloyalty was severely dealt with they
grabbed us they were three of us all
together they tied us up about nine men
held me back first
it was unbelievable I've never felt
anything like it in my life
I thought that we're going to slaughter
Isaac I was struggling and the most
vulnerable are suffering most with
Nigeria on the brink of famine and
forecast it will get worse whilst
they're battling terrorism in the North
and the South they're fighting a
different in the Niger Delta there are
some of the world's biggest oil reserves
few of these people are seeing the
rewards so thirsty
the smoke plume is the work of the oil
thieves burning their stolen crude these
swamps are filled with bandits
kidnappings are rife and no one's safe
so speed is critical one of the oil
pirates is a male a 27 year old now
running a multi-million dollar in licit
business he weaves us through the deltas
labyrinth of waterways to his camp
hidden amongst the mangroves the black
stain you can see on either side is the
oil pollution the platform were walking
on is the deck of a huge barge filled
with crude oil that emo has stolen from
a multinational company operating nearby
he employs nearly 2,000 people the only
jobs they can get the only way to feed
their families
where you live we all will live know the
stealing's hit global oil prices
Nigeria's output fell by a third and
it's not just the economy which is
suffering look at the state of this
water beautiful what was obviously
devastatingly beautiful area thick now
with crude oil and it goes on for miles
these used to be tolerated by those who
benefited but when Nigeria's oil output
dropped the president declared war on
them it hasn't stopped them but many
want to be legalized do you worry that
you're bringing down that is why we are
sitting we are taking to assist us raise
hands we get stopped by a naval patrol
boat but they just demand we hand over
our fuel and move off the deltas full of
militants wanting more of the oil riches
we tracked down one group who gave up
their arms and now feel let down
language they understand is the language
of daguan once Jerid there is a gone
then they Joe has gone listing hours
away whole villages are ruined they
blame shell and want compensation shell
says it's the oil thieves the scene is
apocalyptic this was full of mangroves
at one stage now it's absolutely covered
in oil the water has an oil film over it
even on the boat if you touch it it's
covered in oil you cannot catch anything
nothing again there drinking waters
contaminated their livelihoods are
destroyed and the pollution and piracy
are no closer to being stopped
hopefully our journeys shown you just
how connected we all are we've talked to
those coping with the challenges how do
you feel about having to deal with all
these post abortive problems and aim to
listen to those just surviving what do
you think should be done about it along
the way we've been to places with few
outsiders they had a teeny weeny little
bit of a concern that we might disrupt
the village and they'd all come out and
leave their schooling and we've tried to
give a voice to those not normally heard
it's just a small what happens here
doesn't just affect Africans the rest of
the world too
[Music]
you